welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by Lloyd Hume who is the head
of design for trust in soda which is
across three branches we're in the
London office today he also manages
people in Dublin and Manchester and is
currently managing 8 people across those
free branches in total we've split
between design between contracts in
London cool thank you for adding that
name yeah yeah as I was just saying
we're where I always like to start in
this podcast Lloyd is how did Lord enter
the the lovely world of recruitment
let's start there yeah well for me it
wasn't the same as everyone else that
fell into it mainly what I've always
done sales my whole life and yeah with
that you know if you go to one sales
place and then you leave you kind of
have to start at the bottom again and
there's no like continuation in position
would you used to sell what was really I
think mainly I still hold telecoms so
not like not like you know like top of
saw like kind of stuff but like actual
and full of solutions we saw Westminster
Robbie phone system BT system yeah yeah
it's called voice over IP ok yep a place
is use it now yeah so that I've sold so
have sold modeling appointments so yeah
basically just been in sales in and out
and yeah coming back to recruitment I
just wanted to go somewhere where it can
build on it and then keep with it if I
did you know if it wants to move it's
never my intention to you know to be
around a lot but I just wanted somewhere
that could continue with that was your
friend him was did you have a friend of
equipment in no but I had thought yeah I
did have a friend in recruitment and she
said Lord you need to get into it like
really yeah you smashed the dream yeah
yeah so it wasn't even for her brunch
either so she just said I wanted to into
it yeah fair enough so it's a found luck
a love for sales
did you enjoy sales yeah Oliver its
recruitment sales don't really know oh
you know its sales but so it's a lot
more than that to me so it's you know
it's about it's about building
relationships you know yeah it's
building relationships it's doing a good
job he's still getting the buzz off
finds
on their perfect roll you know it's a
positive the Canada and the client come
you know coming together just doing the
whole process really but you know it's
not transactional thing so we've sales
well I've normally don't you know it's
just yes or no yeah so that's when you
that's why initially said now because of
that I agree that yeah I sell insurance
and if you didn't close them on that
phone call then you're not speaking to
him again yes I totally get that I
totally get that but root is sales at
the same time yeah I mean there's that
for people that don't feel more acrimony
sales I taught there well no yeah it's
definitely element of sales in there but
there is a lot more to it yeah to get to
the sale you need a really good process
so that cool so just to set the scene
then so wanted to get into recruitment
got told about it by a friend wanted to
build on your sales experience and then
so you've been in the industry now so
you've been the trust and soda for how
long
just over two years just over two years
and yeah we should previous to that he
was another agency for a couple of
months yeah so about two and a half
years right obviously as well just to
where you are now did you get promotion
when so I started here as a rookie yeah
I'm a finger promoted six to seven times
from the stars to start here the you
know level yes then I went to associate
than to consultant and to seniors and to
principal I love your head off yes
stepping into the head of role yeah on
say I'm qualified just yeah a lot of
learning to do yeah yeah but they're
pushing in towards that yes automate so
definitely obviously we're the majority
of time on this will definitely
dive into your experience through that
learnings were these lots of things but
there I always like to talk about it
obviously but let's break up so during
the previous company about how were the
first couple of months I met you wanted
to get into industry yeah so how was it
my god the place I worked out with it
was demanding so it was a lot of I was a
lot of cold calling it all day and I
would say like tough enough yeah I would
say cold calling from nine till twelve
and I'm from - who you callin businesses
well yeah we got given a list really
yeah you're going to these and you know
I was I was more than happy I was fine
cold calling people all day I've got no
problem with ah
and then you know one of the people that
was that or speaking to one of my
colleagues and they were like you know
this place isn't that great I was like
really I think it's about I've never you
know this is just normal for me so now
this isn't like what recruitments about
so I started doing a bit of homework
looking in till their agencies that I
found this place so they're safe and so
do you
yeah farm trust in soda it just it spoke
volumes to me it's like is gorg a brand
it's mud because when I turned up for an
interview I was like this the size of it
I thought it was absolutely huge yeah
but it wasn't it wasn't really really
good Brown action is reality right
exactly so so yeah basically begged for
an interview went on the social media I
was looking at what they would call
themselves referring to themselves as
soda lights so I'm a 40 I'm gonna send
them an email I'm going for it so I said
look you know not got much experience I
would love to work for your brand right
you know the way that the way they doing
things I want to be involved about I'd
consider myself a soda light you up for
an interview question mark and then got
a call the next day so everything yeah
okay cool
so how Alan Jim were look at it first 12
months and all in all then so didn't
think how difficult that done
yeah very is is challenging it's just
about you know just being being the best
that you can be obviously you've got
nothing to compare yourself to or you
know you see when you look around in the
business people have been here three or
four years and they're just killing it
it's like how am I ever gonna be that
like you know it's really it's quite
awful yeah yeah so you just think you
know my god you know this person is done
with five deals and I've come and get
some sort of phone call but you know
what I did not just for I'm just gonna
dig my heels in I'm just gonna graft I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be the best like you
know I'm still not the best you know
there's some amazing yeah so that so
you've gone from your rookie yeah to see
where you are now in two years so what
would how like was that Donna Billings
was done on demonstrate value so yeah so
soda it's not just about Billings it's
about
it's demonstrated values by being a team
player being passionate about the
company shown signs and I know being
innovative yeah and yeah so I'm yeah
Billings as well as you know one of the
things but it's like three three key
things yeah really mmm how do you do any
first year that my only but first year
how do billions billions not to me not
amazing I think it did over 150 okay
I have very high expectations in myself
so yeah I just I don't know I always
push for more just think that and that
could be better I'm not I'm not harden
myself for what I do is I look at
something and everything right what
could I've done that's it for next time
and it's just all about constantly
improving yourself like not not doesn't
really matter what level you are there's
always something to learn
have you always had that monster yeah
really yeah where's that come from
they're not everyone yeah I come from a
really really good background
you haven't come from really good back
yeah yeah really wealthy background even
I didn't you know if since was about 17
I started notion of no no handout no
nothing it's just been about like you go
out and get your own it off yeah when
you know you see things that you could
have it's just things I I need to be
something like that
really but you know my my vision is
changed now it's not about being not
really rich and all that stuff is just
by being happy you know been a good time
but you know the money does help feels
bad crying crying in a Bentley turn on
the boss
I'm a horrible way exactly quite in that
but okay so that's the mentality of
wanting to be the best learning all
these types of things yeah you've had to
work on that yeah of course
you know I'm still learning now I don't
think getting ones the finished article
but yeah just just constantly try and be
better so like you know you get your
kpi's when you first start
I look to my kpi's on a year so I got
here looked at my stuff and worked out
so it would be in a year and a father I
need to be nine six months and I
basically reverse and yeah so just
revert reversed it looked or led to be
worked out to get there quicker so this
far do you double the volume in half the
time and then see what happens
double the volume in half the time yeah
how did you do that then I was doing
12-hour days every day really yeah yeah
every day so one time I stayed here till
11:00 at night couldn't get a train home
so just got hotel
today I committed yeah yeah why why
because I want to get the job done what
is to be the best no that's fair enough
and I guess and that was in your first
six months so you yeah do you have a bit
of a chip on your shoulder then yeah
yeah points yeah yeah yeah but um no you
know I just I just wanted to be I wanted
to be something good I just wanted to
make something of myself I like just
thought why not like you know if I'm
gonna be here for nine hours while I'm
here for twelve why don't really push it
you know give yourself give yourself
five days yeah you know just just go for
it okay so so let's break this down a
bit then so let's just let's just talk
about your journey trust and soda so the
first year she said obviously
performance-wise what he did but what
what was you going into here did you
have a warm desk was you're building up
your mom so I was the third higher on
the college track team oh wow yes I know
sort of my previous agency was Jill desk
mechanical desk in here they wanted to
separate that and it was quite hard for
the team to one except you know the
contractor contract and then you know
colleague Lauren and then me the third
higher on the contracts team because
they were all used to jewel desk in so
if you've been used to that then you
know if you've got someone new coming in
Dan you might if you're you know you're
the empress' and you just want to look
after you client yourself I can
understand why you would want to give it
give it
what did you do so what did I have to go
out and find you know fun of my own
stuff you get you get a lot of love it
soda um you know some good clients call
in though you know they'll help you out
with that but you know really what
you're here to do is you know to work
hard they don't want someone you know
just rested on the house account alive
you yeah yeah you know you expected to
get your own stuff as well so did you do
just to help me out so you did what you
did contract from from day one in Saudia
and then now what you do now still doing
the same so I was upon Billa so from
what I understand from working with
crews and these types of things the the
hard part here is getting clients right
yeah it seems like we see the candidate
not that it's easier but there's a lot
more to people you've got people out to
be looking for work put themselves out
there you always get weird people come
to OSU on the contract
recruiters post when they've got a job
you get about 50
different people coming in and also
remote my job a lot easier so so let's
pray that down mate because lie as you
said you had to pretty much build up
from scratch right it was a design
design market you said yeah yeah
so one of the most common things I get
asked about and one of the big struggles
a lot of people have is business about
him at winning clients which is what you
have to do from scratch right so as
you've already said working for a
business like trust and soda advantage
their competitive advantage is they've
got a good brand yeah usually seem
massively house right so how do you
approach building this destined mate how
did that go in hybrid [ __ ] well you know
I was I basically spoke to colleagues in
in the business asked them what they
were doing so I how they get you know
just looking for advice knowledge
sharing always believe is a really good
thing to do seek advice yeah exactly
cause I know I'm so speaking as people
and everyone's like oh what I mentioned
after this or you know I've helped this
team of this mm-hm
so I can't mention any of that because I
was worried about phone in business is
trying to give you know trying to try to
pitch and then then look at me in
sterling and I'm thinking this guy's got
two months experience he especially yeah
is the challenge of course so why start
do mister started selling soda I found
myself a celebrant so yeah just for you
know would look at other companies what
they're doing what we're all what we do
what they on and then I sold on our
problem like we you know we so there is
passion innovation and collaboration
those are our three core values it's
awesome yeah and you know that's what we
go for so I just thought selling the
brand and we've got some wicked events
you know which really do help help you
sell your bun like soda social are women
in DevOps you know we've got loads of
stuff and we've got all these tools that
you can use to get speaking to clients
you know well I'm not just on the phone
trying to trying to get you contracts
yeah yeah I just wanted to tell about so
I put myself on your map and then maybe
when you are hiring you know we can
touch up learn now that you know what I
know that that sounds that may sound not
really simple or basic to you but like I
think that there's a that that speaks a
lot where if you're if you're working
for recruitment business right now and
you don't
leaving their values and you don't
believe in their brand yeah something
about their because a lot of thing
laughter that you're completely right
everything you said before you went into
that people will feel like at the
beginning yeah and yeah like so I think
yeah if you're fewer and if you're in
that type of environment now and you're
listening then 100% what how can you
leverage a business and the brand and I
think that's really smart so events then
this reading shows let's talk about this
for a sec because I think a lot of
people may think that events have been
done I couldn't disagree more so I guess
let's just shed some light on how it's
impacted you so you start leveraging the
brand look look this is this is me this
is what I'm about I can tell you what
I'm gonna deliver and how committed I am
yeah but also let me talk about the
business I work from what we commit and
all that exult and then the event so how
how did that help you then let's just
break that down a bit because I think
that's hugely valuable so what I would
do I mean the exact way I would use it
is you know I would reverse it would
reverse his well on people so I would be
calling calling clients potentials your
prospects and instead of saying his
lawyers pulling for him soda it's loaded
on from soda social I said let them when
they say you recruits it's ain't no I'm
a digital network hims you know sorta
Donovan quite like to have some people
for the company to come down or and then
obviously I was targeting you know who
we wanted to speak there so it's always
a great opportunity to get some of the
phone so look we're doing this event
it's around this I know that you're
interested in that with your background
would you be interested in speaking some
much easy conversation how many how many
how much more time did you get people on
the phone
at least you know that cuz they're
interested in you know people people
like talking about themselves I'm here
so you know when you're telling someone
that you you you know you will be
interested in about my people you know
really warm to that and you know we we
are genuinely interested in people speak
at our events you know we would get
wicked events but like bubble on how
Facebook with Rylan Spotify although
some wicked speak one and what what is
like the typical spill you send like
look like it because typically in your
market people really put like from what
I can see so I've got a couple of people
I know a couple of recruiters in your
market it seems like there's a real
community yeah yeah do you not I mean
I'll say that mastery house if you
recruit and
to be fair that seems like there's so
many markets that they will they will
happily sit in a room for other
competitors like people while winning -
yeah right I think this is what's
changing recruitment now but like was
that it was the typical spill light lerp
and to bind into that there's an
opportunity to give back to the industry
meet like-minded people that that is
pretty much exactly how we did it yeah
and you know it's all true we're not you
know yeah that's not yeah you're not
gonna that doesn't mean you had to take
15 business cards from what I would
always say as well it's like look you
know soda socially is completely
different trusting soda but we do know
the crew in there we don't do anything
we don't you know this is about an event
and we are giving back to the community
and you know we do care and the good
thing about is when you speak into you
know potential hiring manager I will
openly say they'll bring you business
cards I'll do some networking there'll
be some wicked candidates they're gonna
enjoy them and then you know it's just
something was to give to them as well
and nothing that is the punchline is
well like obviously look obviously that
that is gonna draw a bit that's gonna
drive revenue right yeah 100% that that
is gonna that's drivin business but if
your hosts if you're just hosting these
events just on right how many how many
people can we place out of this it's
gonna figure this decision making to put
on an event that you know I mean well
you're not doing an event then for doing
the live only doing an event to monetize
on it so yeah it's completely different
you know you your goals will be
different than lonely yeah no I agree I
think it's surfing is something
obviously you want it to be commercially
worth your time yeah but I think the
right mindset from the beginning is ya
haven't what we're talking about because
then you're gonna be prone to quit
before you even start maybe two events
down I mean okay night so that first
year then what how did you progress in
so in that first year did you get to
what senior consultant or no in the
first year I got I think it made it to
consult him consult yeah and I got
Rookie of the Year no 2017 why do you
feel you go rookie there why come on
watch your feet I think I think you're
just my energy yeah just like with me I
worked really well to to like negative
you know what negative criticism I
McCall do so without better cannon I
love it I'm gonna do it who's you
freezing off then was people he was out
who the hate is mine but basically what
was doing is only loudspeakers friends
and recruitment provide you know I was
thrown in st. Mary's Lisa's heart this
isn't it and all right yeah may and then
you know they're all loving it laughs it
might want to quit Lord I'm gonna quit I
don't know I've made really good friends
with this lot the words of soda okay I
mean him just used to have been at
bucking for often is Lord you think
about calling it day today no it's only
between me and him like something laughs
why have you but you know then just for
actually I'm gonna crush it yeah yeah
and I like like no you always run faster
when someone's chasing you no you know
it's good or if you trying to you know
yours run faster if you're chasing
someone as well so yes competitions are
broken out yeah work ethic determination
and just your mindset around it like you
know with me I just think if you want to
if you want to guess I'm just gonna
apply yourself to it like how if you
have a hard day where your work and
you've not really the loads and then you
know you can't wait to go home then when
you get home you think see how could it
the loads more today actually yeah yeah
that is a horrible feeling
yeah that depends if you actually care
about each of them right it's true yeah
well hopefully if you listen Sudoku yeah
you're right agree so so okay so work
ethic mate yeah the fit I've said this a
couple of times now like how when you
was telling new guys right
coming into your team yeah well you turn
them they got to do these long days no
I'm not saying you have to do it but
lies in like work ethic that that
doesn't feel more flexible working and
work from home and all this all this
yeah what does work if it mean to you
where care fake to me is just just
applying yourself you know being do it
like doing the right stuff you know I'm
just I'm just taking it very seriously
like you know don't don't be any phone
checking Instagram every 10 minutes you
know a lot of stuff like just you know
just just apply yourself and yeah you
know I keep saying it but this is like
my main thing to go to is you know it's
it's the one thing you ever want it or
you don't
and you've just got to be honest with
yourself I do I really want to do yeah
yeah the only reason one was pushing on
that mate because I think in today's
world when you say work ethic these
types of things they think about what
you were talking about when you worked
it to 11:00 p.m.
yes been in the hotel bur now you know
I'm not don't think you have to do that
to be successful I mean yeah that's
cause because you know you should always
people always say work smarter not
harder
yeah I fought I'll work harder and
smarter there's no there's no shortcut
you got you got to pull it in like that
that's that's my thing with it is light
there's sacrifice its sacrifice it to be
made if you want to be if you're serious
about and you'll be someone that has
committed yourself and and it's okay if
you're someone that doesn't want to come
inside fine it depends what your own
right and it's personal to you and you
know some people are families like you
don't want to be in an office why don't
you be allowed to be in an office of
your family yeah but I didn't really you
know I didn't realize or anything really
have anywhere to be
and I may know me why not like I'm gonna
take the thing is I don't really party
on a school night anyway I still call my
school like yeah you know like with me
Monday to Monday or maybe some
Thursday's yeah well yeah you know so if
I mean work tomorrow yeah yeah I'm here
so why not be here a bit like yeah
something not more is interested to ask
people because I think they it's come
off a couple of times like how how many
big bill is were you surrounded by have
interests when you were yeah when you
was in the think of that first year or
so you got rookie the year you did well
Bert yeah like how yeah how many big
brothers are you surrounded by well
there's three different brands here all
owned by one so there's about three or
four from each round yeah so how do you
speak man how do you think that how do
you think that sort of impacted you when
I first came I was intimidated by well
you know why actually because one of the
people I looked up to from one of our of
the Browns he I was asked in for his
advice like you didn't deal why did you
do that why because if some people won't
yeah well why did you just go and ask
him collaboration is one of our main
points you know you talk neat
collaborative with people but I did that
because I thought this guy he knows what
he's doing you just tell ya and I just
fought what did you ask him I said look
what are you doing I'm doing like tell
me about your day plan somehow you spoke
to yourself like what you doing that I'm
not and he's like look you know it's
just it's just you know keep shaking the
tree and somebody's because someone's
gonna draw shaking the tree yeah just
keep shaking it someone's gonna bounce a
falldown and if it doesn't you pull my
shaking hard enough for you looking up
the wrong tree but it's definitely gonna
be something out there so anyway we've
got once I started you know doing better
here and I forget it emailed me and he
just said you have arrived
yeah yeah nice I really liked it
and just quickly on that because again I
think a big part this is the business
you work from stuff for that basically
scam its k-much so it's came up so many
times that if like seek advice I know it
sounds so simple in it but there'll be a
lot of people that will be sitting in
the corner like not they're worried
about us also how receptive was he
because you work for quite big big
business here right so to walk over to
the biggest pitler who you may perceive
as has no time Lloyd the rookie likes
you not I mean Celaya
Howrah said it wasn't me different but
how receptive was he actually when you
when you look me I'd love to know what
you don't you know well I really hope to
open my head for time last yeah this I
look forward ha just gonna do it don't
you yeah just so anyway winner over
excuse me anyway yeah this big situation
I'm glad you said that so I think to
finish that off if you listen what now
you look up to someone in the office
yeah of course
awesome awesome fact yeah but are they
did not only that like don't sit in the
corner suffering in silence because it's
gonna be a lot of a different moment you
know be a miles different conversation
saying well if you've done all day
nothing because I didn't ought to do or
we do you know see so final point on
that what do you think was the biggest
thing you took away from him then would
you say this is vice so you mentioned
right day-planner structure yeah
definitely
I love talking about structure don't be
a busy fool don't be a fool so you know
you've got to first of all commitment
and by you like if you're speaking small
on the phone oh yeah you can have that
job and then yeah straight oh you're
great at the beginning now you're
buzzing you know it's so it's so bad -
when you see training or real key or you
know someone's not loads of experience
get really excited about role because
you hope your new pray from there it was
gonna come off but you know they they're
not qualified to properly then it's not
really gonna happen so here we try to
make sure that doesn't hurt so funny you
say that because I can't remember who I
had this conversation with but we had
this exact conversation and then he was
like and then he was just like yeah and
then when they get off the phone and
then you ask him a couple of questions
about the job
we make we say you have to call back so
it's a structure what what your
non-negotiable is in your structure now
sure they're still there you have 10
before 10 10 before it just sounds good
it could be 11 for 11 12 14 10 of what
so that's speaking to 10 candidates okay
totally a.m. yeah I just you know bit
just been on top I know you're focusing
on yeah before 10 a.m. yeah 10 before
10:00 so speaking yeah and I find I get
these candidates the night before you
know work out I'm going to talk to
they're gonna be relevant to me you
can't you can't you know literally load
up a job board or something like that if
you wanna take that book with me I think
you want to be you know what more
targeted than that and I would have
roles a lot of them would be referrals
as well always ask for a referral only
friends are looking into colleagues
anyone you dress I was gonna say again
conversational had if you're a contract
recruiter like how important is it to
leverage your candidate market it
through that yeah absolutely because you
know contractors that all on sight of
each other and they'll all come back in
you know it's just it's a circle they
always always working with each other so
you say even if the ten calls are hi
Lloyd look just want to check in your
contracts up in a couple of months like
just for I'll give you a quick call do
you know what's gone on the mark at the
moment have you had anything that's
coming up yeah exactly that could be 10
of those calls as well should be like
new people know
Cuvier could be existing existing
candidates could become the list you got
in the run in you know if you've got a
candidate with one interview for you and
three for someone else you want to be on
the phone to him making sure see what's
going on you know race probably he's
probably you know you need to be aware
I'd always say good recruiters are the
ones that ask the questions that you
don't want to know the answers are right
here when I realize that yeah when I was
in recruitment I was a lot oh my god
that's so true because early on you
don't want you don't ask him like you'd
rather like now now Donna push on Nancy
and then you blow yet it still has done
right it's done but you know I messed up
my first deal it would kill me but
basically what happened was did I speak
of candidates being to decline have the
interview liked each other you know
phones more texts sounded him out
she always failing and his outlook Lloyd
you know I'll tell you that all mate he
just just tell me I've got it's yours
Sonya now for what's gonna make my boss
more happier and you know just sit at
home watching me send the daily mail
around on a Saturday so I got the email
from the client late the Friday night
sound oh yeah little go for it so I just
fought great I'm just gonna bring
running in straightaway didn't consult I
know I'm still a rookie at this time and
it's all I'm just gonna do it and be the
boy oh happy yes IP you've got the roads
are but I think about it like what I
think you told me you told me thank you
as I ask something else is come on all
right Dan around me bosses that look if
the laces.i wife you don't know I don't
know we know this is why we have these
processes in place like you know just
you stick to the process and it's fine
you might I appreciate each other thing
but you gotta deal so it's on your head
says all right cool is that let it be a
learning curve to you don't know from
that one mmm and the one said you know
there's a lot of mistakes to make him
accrue though I just want just don't
make the same one twice like if you slip
up on something then you know just to
make sure we don't do it again it's not
the end of the world
yeah and I think that's at but I
honestly love that advice so much ask
the questions you don't hear the answers
yeah because that will produc will get
you uncomfortable with watch the
questions that you need to know the
answer to that gives you as much
confidence on what should happen
and you know if you know your market
and/or the market there and you know you
like and you want to learn more about it
and you really do need to nail down on
this
I know existence one of your other
podcasts and I kept saying double down
and I love that you know like double
down on any process double down what you
don't do
I'm Billy I think that's really true
like that is what you need to do if you
don't want to ask someone about you know
how many other honey mothers you got
work on this you might really be wasting
your time at the beginning you can be
really prone to that because it feels
uncomfortable using this lot of fun
lashes I thing is I just remember
horrible pressure that given myself I
need to get a job and need to do do you
don't need to do those things obviously
they all come with time but don't stress
yourself out put too much pressure on
yourself watching everyone else do deals
and then just getting bogged down when
they just thinking you know like this
can't do it and that's why you will
support those questions because when
you've got the small wins you celebrate
them a bit too much like you know just
stick to the process any other good ten
so I've cooked 10 candidates yeah it's
10 a.m. yeah my doing next May and the
Lord day your daily database by 10:00
till 12 something on the beedi beedi
obviously a lot of people don't answer
what have you you tend to focus on Yass
Beatson who's a on 10 to 12 you work for
trust
so to social don't forget to the moon
yeah it is because you know when you
speak to a hundred people a day or a
hundred people in a week you all not to
remember every conversation you have
there's nothing worse than you know I'm
actually wearing a pedometer and we
tried to rear is awesome for Volvo
exactly [ __ ] happens but you know those
are just those mistakes that you make
when you are when you first start like
being really quiet on the phone
scatting everyone's gonna hate you in
the office my stand up and do it one but
yeah so um in the afternoon then from
one yeah from what so once it's like 12
yeah that's launching that but after
that in the afternoon I'll probably jump
on sort of social something like that
stop and look at that market information
marketing my friend speaking to more
candidates see what's going on going
through you know people who've got
applied for roles what I've you just
going through that well just all the
general stuff is just one good bit of
activity on the board really but unless
unless you got a role there and I should
prioritize yeah but yeah I like that so
yeah half your day there's obviously an
element of being strategic and what's
going on bah blah blah and yet
leveraging your network and speak to
people but 10 before 10 10 to 12 get you
sort of being like going to you people
just works just sound be flexible with
it but I think what in my experience so
I work for a business for 12 people so
at the beginning I was [ __ ] scared of
people listening while buying that but
when we when was also all building out
our Desson all like as a collective
focus and we did like two hours just
focus on business development like that
massively helped yeah and it was a
crystal clear we measured it like from
the point where we decided every 10th
word so every Tuesday infers there would
always be BD the amount of jobs will be
pulled and the things we were pulling
had a massive impact of course I think
if you're doing the same thing at the
same time yeah but just actually having
a focus and I've had to this my own
business now like for me blocking out
hour by hour also can be flexible with
it but having a complete focus on Wanda
in this hour massively helps and my I'm
just way more productive because
especially in recruitment like there's
so many things that you could be doing
there so anything that you like oh yeah
I'll reply to that or reply to this
email whatever like there's so many
things that you could do that really if
you just kept in eyes don't amount to
what what you need no I think yeah you
definitely gotta be clever with it but
you know when you first start this this
is something that you don't understand
how to do so you know you doing you told
look what other people are doing but and
you know until you work out how best you
work yeah
that's when you know that's when you
you start basically working to the best
account so when did you start managing
people I'd say about six seven months
ago
yeah yeah how have you how have you
found that transition may be honest
you're smoking yeah it's you know it's
been tricky because we have some great
leadership and management courses which
really really helps
they've really helped both working when
he just worked for yourself in principle
and you worry about your own things that
it's quite hard to transition into you
know and so helping someone else you
don't want to manage yeah okay Affairs
yeah that's not always a case right so
you did you was my evade - yeah managing
I I really like it because you know
after you've done X Mark you know deals
it's like yeah it's good it's a good
feeling but when you can help someone
and teach them how to do something and
only see the penny drop and then see
them do a deal like yeah buzzing you
want to send those emails around again
you have a right let's talk about that
that mate so I guess she wanted to me
you wanted to manage got to a point
where you officer I'm sure you was in
cars internally we should demonstrating
the right things and you wanted to do it
so that transition is definitely
challenged a lot of people have yeah so
I'll see you urine at six seven months
in so you're in and out right so I guess
what what you were just talking about
there so you've gone from just haven't
worried about yourself yeah you're on
billions around performance obviously
then I'm sure you help some people along
the way but yeah now you've got an
actual you have to help these people
right it's your role yeah that's what
you're getting paid to do yeah I mean so
how how have you found that transition
like so to when the first style so I'm
not blanks in in my quite some time how
the first month of have really trainee a
blank sort of felt to feared God for I
did not didn't trust myself away Madonna
for you can do this so therefore where I
come to do this so straightaway you're
getting the imposter syndrome
so yeah just for a moment definite I
don't have done this for as far as you
know it fell about your first day all
right
yeah you don't need to feel all this you
can do it and I just remember just just
sitting down and thinking Raj needs to
sort this out and then did the same is
gonna go here you know about where when
it's a Bay the new tournament vision the
team that want to have how we're gonna
do that and then working so I I want to
be known for the bat well not me I want
solar to be known for the best design
team in my London you know recruitment
I've got a big guy yeah that's what I
want I just you know yeah it's
achievable is it may see that's just
something I want same fourth now and the
way I'm doing that so my experience is
you come into recruitment to give you
desks potatoes roasting hearts probably
absolutely not
I'm heroes and I to just said a lot you
are building this up from the ground but
instead of me coming here being de
motivated you know I'm not saying that
was but you know some days are really
challenging what I've done now is I'm
building up there so I look after the
whole spectrum of design and research I
want to do with these is I build the
desktop I've got them you know piping
heart and then when I bring the training
for the monster like that's gonna give
them what a soft London with it I'm
still expected to do their own things to
go you know give me a split with their
boys just something to keep them engaged
motivated so that's been the strategy
yeah okay what for the last six seven
months you've been well she didn't do
that for the first about your point so
you you've you've really spent you but
okay so you had a tough first month
blank first time for a while yeah and
then what you made it time to go
actually okay why am I doing this
yes what do I want out this what I want
it to look like yes so I'll tell you
what it was the the second bumper
actually had external training coming in
which was two days you know two days
here two days a great time for me to
just really knuckle down and get on with
my stuff yeah he's got a training out
all day and fought yeah amazing so it
really took you know really use that
time to my advantage and then then what
I learned it was about you know again
with your timings and how are you how do
you structure your day was instead of
just you know being on the back and core
whenever they want yeah it's what I'd
write so you know we'll catch up after
time so we'll do we'll do ten before
telling them we'll catch up after we'll
see what when Ryan what went wrong but
more could have gone better and then
we'll catch up again after the next
assignment and then you know it's keep
catch you know obviously there's a few
bits
in there what you wanted to encourage
these people to be like right this is
what this is this is your intention for
the next couple of let's let's talk
about how when and what lon
always lead from the front I do I sit
there doing the same thing with them as
well so yes you're a billing manager
right yeah so okay so what going through
that then if I'm if I'm transition right
now and I'd on a blank how do you
definitely could because my next
question to which I write down which was
because it's come up a lot is like a lot
of people go through that so I'm a I'm a
good biller and I really like the
prospects of managing want to manage
people however typically I may not for
them my billing is going to take a drop
yeah and take a hit right so know what
you know now he's six seven months it's
obviously still London right but
obviously the great thing about
hindsight what what would you did
differently do you think to give the
best possible chance or not blank in
that first one thing every time ashamed
to tell you which you don't do is I
decided there was some area coming but
what time of year it was yeah but there
was it worked out that if you took a few
days off and you're like three to four
weeks off for the cost of eleven you
know where the bank holidays like
someone did a month traveling in
Columbia you did yeah yeah I'm just so
I'm just gonna go dip I'll for this and
then it came back and basically the
world what I'm getting to here is just
build your pipeline up if you're if you
don't know what's gonna go on so
basically as well I did the deals while
I was in Colombia so I'm still I you
know still on bohon taught you know
talking to clients YV obviously in
different times but I basically did all
my pipeline in Colombia wasn't building
the pipeline so just basically to play
today so definitely I don't do that but
Columbia's great do you go there but
make sure you've got some pipeline for
you too I know but yeah I would have
just built my pipeline on massively
you know Dan speeds people and then you
know engage with you with your clients
and you come in as well let me know
what's going on like you know keep them
keep them in the loop prevent what
you're growing a team yeah yeah grown a
team we're gonna be hiring in this you
know we're gonna be recruiting in this
time sector this they saw the other you
know where can we add some more volume
now obviously I know you you said that
you really enjoyed the James episode but
that's something that he said actually
when she's really interesting he said
that he bought the clients on the
journey yeah like he's like look like
we've been working together I'm a grown
team that this wouldn't like as dim like
they actually yeah brought them into
what you're trying to build a that's a
great advice so some of my some of my
client calls are so ridiculous because
people enough is like who you talking to
because I'm talking about Netflix we did
it the weekend like kids birthday
parties one thing I used to do as well
which actually can't really good buy-in
from air coming it's in clients that's
come on they do not like what you doing
tonight
well we deal there all right let me tell
you and your phone about the next thing
[Laughter]
okay so how some of the key things that
you've done different nylons you've got
a bit more of a structure and then
something that you did talk a bit about
you would send it you've got a bit more
of a strategy now so before you start
growing your team you're trying to
obviously build a bit of that's only
obviously for designed that what I can
help with design because that's what I
do however contracts teams getting more
than design yeah so we've both you know
work would be seen at the moment
something lucky as well so why did you
do that like so why for review building
a bit of a platform yeah I was how have
you found that that has helped people
that come in that completely fresh
really well because it gives them a
chance that obviously we're not just
gonna go yeah he's you know is a role
working yeah there'll be a role coming
in that's in that market don't sit there
with me
will do the role why have you go through
the whole process and I just you know
let them shadow you doing it and just
let me know this is that market this is
who they're gonna be speaking to and
then taking them out of meetings involve
them and everything but I don't just go
out you know leave the real keys on his
desk what have you you know take them
out with you but I talk to him Arnie
stars everywhere with me candidate
climby and yeah everything to keep them
involved and then how involved are you
in hiring for your team yeah just way
too high off him in Ohio last week
already
yeah someone's got a master's in design
really exciting yeah so how many people
do hard so far then to read three
highest so far really yeah
any learnings a because typically harm
for your own team is definitely one of
the biggest challenges yeah they still
here yeah
so how any learnings there for people
yeah I would say always hire for
attitude and not for skills skills can
be taught attitude can't think about you
culture fit as well like what what you
know what's a team like you work over
the moment you see them fitting in there
I always go out for like maybe welcome
drinks why have you like to come meet
the team but what we do is well now is
it's not just senior people who
interview candidates it soda so we
everyone takes a go of it so does my if
you're a new trainee if you're whether
like going up a chocolate person's do
you think so basically just gives you
know really good really good feedback
from everyone you can see like what the
general what are the I was not asking
that's like what the non-negotiables
that you look for when for you teams you
mentioned culture you mention attitude
what the non-negotiables female I don't
think I've come across like I don't
think I've had one thing which is a
non-negotiable for me I mean obviously
culture for me if you're not really not
like this you know feeling with the
culture and that's just fine and then
that's a well yeah that's pretty much it
will really say I've got a
non-negotiable because I think everyone
has skills to bring to the table it
depends where you can see them fitting
with you that's good answer mate so what
I wanted to definite dive in with you
mate is your personal brand yeah so
let's talk about cuz I'm mostly banging
the drum of it but I'd love to hear your
story of it may obviously I went on your
LinkedIn you've got an article saying
it's about how have the market yeah and
I really enjoyed that so let's just talk
I love to just hear your story of it for
people listening so where and how if
anyone hasn't seen so Lloyd has got some
quirky say to say so like how how did
you start okay so you put you put a post
on LinkedIn I've got I'm Lloyd I've got
this job does it all my name no one say
don't even interested in reading it and
then you look at your thing and it's
gonna engaged about five people so I
thought right what's gonna stand out
you're all humans you're like looking on
our phones all i-beams a lot of stuff
gifts whatever
so I'll just fall right
Photoshop so farm so they started
someone photo shops yeah and I put
myself in somewhere with situations like
I remember being hurrying mekansm I get
wet in here
so I Photoshop myself into the way to
move them yeah my people I he's done so
so did that been one of my favorites was
it got a picture of REM Photoshop myself
in the corner and I hadn't found the
photo yeah yeah oh yeah so uh Ellie wait
so these are REM which is a band okay
you got a song called I don't know the
songs call but he says that's me in the
corner is one of the lyrics so I got a
photo of them and I photoshopped myself
in the corner and look what I found this
photo of me and REM last night I'm
watching the corner or as opposed in the
same stuff so yeah yeah so just for
advertisement job people won't look at
what I'm writing but they look at the
image and then because he looked at the
image to say who's this and then they
looked at my post and he started working
massive it loads attractiveness started
you know I think was about six for him
saying I did I did was six months in
yeah wasn't you [ __ ] scared of like
coming across like how did you go
overcome that because that's the biggest
so I had this idea
iris say it was the best mom so what
yeah so basically northern oven
obviously but you don't want to move to
here went around defending everyone I'm
saying hi talking to people me too but
you don't do that not what have you and
anyway so I did this I got you know the
old photo over England on a Photoshop
myself in front of it was like a weather
map and it basically wrote about you
know in the north it's kind freezing on
free cuz it was always cold obviously
you know just did loads of wordplay on
that but I deal about basically I played
on that from Manchester been done uh
yeah
prayin up for Manchester people in the
south and then in the Midlands where no
one's really quite sure what's going on
obviously is not true but just having a
yeah I'm so did that first idea yeah
yeah so that was the first idea talking
about four weeks to post it really was
you worried about it's just first of all
someone just burying me online going how
how did you overcome that then well just
fall right so
again someone's tell me to shut up
probably be a legend home it's a risk
I'm willing to take so I did it yes yes
what actually happens like absolute [ __ ]
scared life yeah so well actually how I
uploaded it ever did hell regret saying
this file oh they didn't tell me link to
love archive or Jess don't work a lot
and I mean busca movies I hope my boss
laughing laughing ah it's not lit up
post is amazing and I was like wow he's
like yeah it's amazing
Stefan I was like thanks cool you're
like Ewing it's like yeah alright she
leave some money wait yeah definitely so
so then did that that mean that anyone
else's opinion was irrelevant not
irrelevant no because thought yeah but
you know there's a weight lifted off my
shoulders
yeah yeah which massively helps I think
that's a key point there there you had
some internal buy in there yeah that
does help because it's like there's yeah
you don't want just random and it's just
absolutely bearing you online but you
don't want people in the office that you
see every day going bad loads of weird
it's obviously other people's opinions
online but also internally as well
especially when they're the new per six
months it
what was that person I was trying to
convince someone to do video and all
that and I was the least experienced in
there so it's like so yeah okay cool so
you just just did it basically and then
and then since then yes I just gets the
punchline how has it made you more money
right so now I've got clients ringing in
saying that speech Lloyd I said well I
have to know about me said you're like
kid that does the videos so I've got a
soul video like either talking about
buying from a company the last video
cost my boss hundred fifty quid I can
made him buy me a soar outfit really
Icicle have you seen this or one but I
mean the Grinch the Grinch having the
Grinch got like 30,000 views PVI people
just like this is amazing man it's such
a warmer conversation but does he go to
digital buy at me oops
design me oh my god you're Lloyd are you
doing so because clients Ringo up and
once I pulled in what's the punchline
yeah I know also I think is well it's
just for your confidence like you know
if you have people celebrating your wins
you know looking up - I got candidates
and clients ringing me same wins
watching next video on yeah Susanoo and
he just called and yeah I was talking to
my friend leave an isle aside it's just
madness isn't it laughs of comics really
quitting I'm really really grateful for
it because I actually it's insane right
you know just what's happened and my
company lambie's put these stupid videos
online but we have these social events
like I'm DJ so take my decks down there
yeah DJ for everyone coming in like it's
just I've already look like a dude
remain to run that off then yeah look
crews work hard yeah it has it has its
main what hasn't made you mama
how's it help yeah bill I've got yes
help magic yeah how because what it is
is when you get this engagement off
these posts your your name cease
cropping up in a lot of conversations
people put you know companies approached
us to work with them people from other
companies are asking about how it marks
in laughs market is one the companies
approach to me like this any like huge
win though that's a win that you will
never forget
yeah comments in the client Lane yeah
yeah but like said what happened then
you put a job I pulled about five or six
offers yeah just love this straightaway
unfortunately didn't really go that well
but yeah you had that was like yeah easy
over 50 groundswell business and yeah it
would have been if I mean what recurred
you know if seven months experience gets
people bringing in sinks we saw Lloyd it
was the videos so and it's just all
about you know getting your brand out
there get your name out there because
there's over 60,000 recruitment agencies
in Europe you know and fasteners would
be doing the same thing so stand out be
different find you've okay so advice for
people that are [ __ ] scared and want to
start yeah how would you say well so
first of all know your audience there's
some some markets out there that I can't
Dave you know just depend like design
wild love design like the design is like
the lovely smirk like friendliest people
in the world will have a conversation
about anything you know really
knowledgeable and I think designs a
really cool market anyway like you know
what so you were saying there and
they're more receptive to life
definitely yeah
ya know you mark it and then think about
what you want to achieve from this you
don't want to be some meme guy or some
you know you want to make you get
something out of this I have a target or
you know some sort of warmth out of it
what was your mom's just to get to get
my name out there I just wanted to be I
wanted to be so when I phone I always
thought if I found someone you know
photo company trying to speak to someone
there he said he was they say Lord Jim
don't know a luteum is and I forgot my
LinkedIn this keep seeing this lawyer
yeah it's that just so powerful
yeah they are know about guys like winch
video what why not try it yeah so it's
know your audience so bear that in mind
before you decide to start making greens
for do you get that and then and then
the next one is I have like a good
actual goal I don't just do it for the
sake of it yeah that's a good thing and
then also as well lastly what I would
say is the most important is be
committed to it so I do mine I'll do one
a month well I mean some people might
say an ass not enough Lloyd no what you
brought you put in yeah I think that's I
think that's a good only that's all
video something about three nights the
right drive yeah that's what I mean like
the fun yeah putting that much into it
yeah I think yeah so be committed yeah
be committed about not just be
consistent because if you're just doing
a video I wasn't wearing or you know and
again yeah just be consistent there's
nothing for me I think it's just like
when you see a real critter go hi guys
to make my first video they don't see
him again like three six months but be
commit yeah be committed and you know
what you're not gonna get 10,000 views
any first well you know yeah it comes
back to why doing it right if you if
you're a recruit and you're doing it
because you want a better chance for
candidates or clients to know who you
are then like somebody it's not about
that it's about getting the reach and
why how and do you did anyone bear you
lot how do you do how do you do it like
how was that for you like cuz you [ __ ]
scared about putting out there like now
I think I buried myself more than anyone
yeah yeah so you're putting some green
tights on and at some zoo in a green
mask yeah you're not really you know you
are asking for it like it's gonna happen
I don't know I'm like I will bounce or
anyone why I love it's just laughs isn't
yeah but you know I was expecting here
boy actually touchable it never happened
wasn't as bad yeah and that again that
that's the sort of punchline there for
me it's a lot honestly what is the worst
that can happen
yeah and if you've got some light just
absolutely no better just trying to bury
you then me it's like I'd feel sorry for
him because it's like yeah they had
taken time out a day to leave a comment
on your post yeah what you're talking
about you've got some 2-bit idea you
know a flex in his opinion with you yeah
it's like whatever yeah it's just like
wow also what it does do for you if
someone does try and throw you on line
the good thing is if you know if you can
think of it like that is you will get
more traction because yeah yeah yeah so
I think I love that this is a real
honest account on to see you put
yourself out there and how it's I think
all our sort of just add my two pence on
there for me is just there's so many
people not doing anything like you might
you might be connected with Lloyd though
you might see what people do nicely
lesbian videos all this but honestly I
said part of what I do of all my clients
as I will say I will say give me two of
your top direct competitors and I've
learnt a shitload of people now and
honestly like 90% of the people that
I've let's say well over 200 people now
they look faceless there's not there's
not a lot if Lloyd biddies many now and
the the Lord down the road that does
exact so market be these me the chances
of me checking out your LinkedIn profile
are extremely high and if there's
nothing on there to demonstrate or
communicate why I should go back to
Lloyd over the other Lloyd then that's
the point I'm in and that that's the
thing and I think that's the most
important thing and that's why is it
just huge opportunities to get a lot of
country right now because everyone is
[ __ ] scared like you said beginning but
you got over there and you reap the
rewards of it
yeah do it and if you you know if you
didn't want to I've actually had
consultants add me and say would you
give me some advice in there so I've
actually give advice to other people and
in recruitment evideos yes definitely I
think that was a real honest account on
you going through that process mate so
fair play right so
a couple of questions on resilience Oh
see you'll come to the event on you yes
yes so I was have event coming up in
March on resilience cultivating
resilience and going the distance in
recruitment yeah so I got a couple
questions for you before we finish so
the first one is what does resilience in
recruitment mean to you I think it's
about not letting everything affect you
like understand understand what can go
wrong part you know the criminal is
quiet process understand why could go
wrong I always expect the worst hope for
the best
like you know yeah yeah it's true just
just don't put your eggs in one basket
and it's so demoralizing and so
soul-destroying when you've done so much
bathing and get one me and then the
council on the day right oh my god and
you know the thing is when you when you
see people get you know really torn up
about put down you just see it affect
the rest of the day no don't just don't
let it you know take I was to do as you
say to malign manager I'm really pissed
off can I just listen to purchase two
minutes so go yeah sure go upstairs put
me headphones in listen some horrible
techno something whatever I just get in
the mood so yeah so also I think that's
grants man I think also like you know
what know what can help you get all that
fun yeah so with with me I know that
sometimes alarming it moved I know I'm
gonna be in this mood for ages and I
think don't do again I don't do that
what could be did Scott nude listen some
music I take two minutes that literally
yeah I went on this mismanagement course
and the guy said to me it was really
cool actually I've done it but you like
to Ponca but he goes ahead goes get
younger I put it in a box like imagine a
box in front of you know all these box
up and get your anger in it and then go
outside and throw it as hard as you can
on the floor and I tell you oh ma
young is actually gone really wait
that's awesome okay next one this is
probably something that you're
definitely going through now I'm
actually that's the next one so how how
has the importance or needful resilience
changed as the industry is
vote do you think I think is it's
changed you need to be more and more
resilient now you know this there's a
lot of new kids coming out these those
businesses cropping up coming on site
with clients there's loads of stuff
going on now and now I think it's about
you know I always think with it role of
your get rolled over so you got to move
at the times mmm because if you've been
doing it you know your old school stuff
and your horse and carts outside and you
best to empower the kids you need to you
need to move with the times really and
resilience will come from that and
understanding where you are working on
what you're doing
it'll just give you the opportunity to
look at everything in front of you you
know just don't what people do we do
just bury the head in the Sun with these
things like I just face it head-on just
grab the bull by the horns and I accept
you know there are gonna be some of
those days you know so I'm gonna be some
bad days what have you bought you know
start keep pushing freely nice last one
so what can people do themselves to
instill resilience in them or their
teams okay so people who basically
people who experience you know I being
stressed out all the time I'm not not
sure to manage themselves or what have
you like that they is really bad
financial health
you know recruitment is a very stressful
game so what would say is you know don't
don't be scared of having or being upset
it's cool to be you know it's cool to
get down but it's also cool to manage
that as well and I think what you can do
to build resilience in maybe yourself
all around you is to 1 understand what
is the skinny down to work out how to
not do that again or how you could maybe
work around it so that won't happen 3 be
positive on a team if you're Scott some
leg you dancing in the corner yeah so
you don't need a butt up would you would
you do those people so I've got rules so
look I understand that this is hard I
would prefer you to text or email me
throw me down bay or something you know
something's going on that you want help
with or you want to run yeah and go for
meeting room yes you said to people look
like you're you even though you may not
feel like it but your energy does affect
over PA so when you're often like I have
a [ __ ] day let me know
do it together of course did you know
just just let me know but if someone's
on a high like oh my god you know I've
got this pulled out jobs just willing to
count got me and you got someone in the
corner crying so you know I'm not saying
them on cries in the corner so that's
not like that here yeah I know man no
yeah so just you know positive just be
positive
oh yeah so just what really is about
positivity attitude and knowing that all
those are some ways fell in his face
there's 10,000 million other clients out
there like this you know yeah you think
yeah I think when people first start
recruitment it's why he gets so hungry
first account when he first this yeah
and you know you really fight for that
you hold on to it
and I get that but looking back and up
now the amount of time I wasted holding
on to accounting wasn't worth holding on
to
yeah just like you know speed someone
get some advice on it like you know ask
you pears some seniors like it man
so before I ask you the final question
on what are you excited about my man
Oh makes I hear it's nineteen twenty and
beyond I'm gonna get mortgages yeah oh
yeah is that gonna be in London or North
that's gonna be in London whereabouts
are you aiming for hope in I really
liked where I live at the moment which
is like Civic Burma ziwei I live in Bora
do you know for coffee is yes I run that
yes lovely yeah you want to get a place
right now yes really realistic you try
Kania so yeah that's what pretty much
what I'm doing so I'm not not treating
myself as much anymore you know doing it
out on sale I'm boring they're worried
but um yeah I'm just I'm focusing you
have focusing on getting the mortgage on
I'm yeah you know I'm a bit older than
these lot here 31 years old I need to be
bending somewhat mom I've run on live
ten eleven holidays last year comes
[Laughter]
cool so you're excited about well my
excites yeah definitely a few things
Podcast then super excited for that yeah
it's not gonna be the only event this
year got a few got a few fingers cooking
yeah yeah excites help more recruiters
so I just just feeling grateful and just
excited have your life thank you mate
and final question go on
so if Lloyds could communicate to every
single recruiter out there they take on
your advice said listen could be a word
a phrase whatever comes to mind what are
you saying to the people I've touched on
it before but if it's if it's regarding
you know you work and get out there I
would say just keep shaking the tree
yeah I love that so keep shaking the
tree because it will drop it will come
and no matter how hard it like [ __ ] that
feels or looks like it isn't it will up
and just stick with it keep checking the
trigger Lloyd it's been a pleasure mate